now we go to jet Piquet's with that
leaked NSA report on Russia and the
election Geoff good morning good morning
the top-secret report was completed just
last month and is an indication that US
investigators continue to gather new
information about Russian efforts to
interfere in the election investigators
believe there were repeated intrusion
attempts by Russian hackers in the final
days of the campaign mr. dusty Vladimir
Putin has consistently dismissed US
intelligence assessments yes I haven't
seen even once any direct proof of
Russian interference in the presidential
election in the United States but a top
secret NSA report first published on the
website the intercept says hackers from
Russian military intelligence were
trying to access voter registration
information days before the election the
report some of which is redacted says
hackers stole user credentials from a
u.s. election software company in
Florida then just over a week before the
November 8th election the hackers used
those credentials to send fake emails
laced with malware to 122 local
government officials likely involved in
the management of voter registration
systems what was your initial reaction
when you found out that this was the
Russians hacking into the system shock
and dismay
obviously Arizona's secretary of state
Republican Michelle Reagan told us last
summer that Russian hackers had been
probing her state's voter information in
the months leading up to Election Day at
the time Arizona
Illinois Florida and nearly two dozen
other states saw similar scanning
probing or breaches of their election
systems I think the real intent of this
was for somebody to tell us that they
could get information if they wanted to
to scare us into thinking that our
elections aren't safe and that is the
most dangerous thing of all US officials
have consistently said that they do not
believe Russian hackers actually
affected the vote count or the outcome
of the election and even with this new
information sources say they stand by
that assessment but intelligence
officials
you this new information as further
confirmation that Russia interfered in
the 2016 election this morning the
Kremlin again denied any involvement
Nora
alright Jeff thank you so much